في اليوم التاسع من المواجهات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع دول عده
تسابق الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها من السودان
وتغلق السفارات هناك اما السودانيون
فيتاهبون ربما لمعركه كبيره بين رفاق
السلاح مع قرب انتهاء هدنه لثلاثه ايام
كانت حبرا على ورق مئات القتلى والجرحى
وازمات في قطاعات عده بدات تظهر ابتداء من
الصحه مرورا بالكهرباء والمياه وحتى
الاتصالات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رغم الهدوء الحذر مشاهدينا ميدانيا بين
الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع تتواصل
الاشتباكات بشكل متقطع في العاصمه الخرطوم
فيما شهدت بعض احياء بحري وام درمان
والخرطوم تحليقا للطيران الحربي بحسب شهود
عيان من جهات اخرى اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع طيران الجيش بقصف مواقعها في منطقه
كافوري بالخرطوم بحري هذا ويتواصل
الانقطاع في خدمه المياه وفي مدينه بحري
وعدد من احياء ولايه الخرطوم ومن المقرر
ان تنتهي مساء اليوم هدنه كان وافق عليها
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بينما تواصلت
حركه النزوح من الخرطوم الى الولايات
السودانيه الاخرى
وفي هذه الاثناء اعلن المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر
يوسف ان النزاع الحالي في السودان سيكون
سببا في ضياع البلاد دون استعادتها مؤكدا
انها حرب لن ينتصر فيها اي طرف على الاخر
يوسف اشار الى ما اعتبرها فرصه متاحه
حاليا لايقاف الحرب وتشكيل جبهه مدنيه
لتجاوز الازمه الراهنه كما اكد على اهميه
واولويه اجتماع الاطراف العسكريه والمدنيه
على طاوله الحوار لتوصل الى حل دائم
النصر اللي انا
طالما المطر
مع استمرار خرق الهدنه تبادل الطرفان
الاتهامات بشان الاعتداء على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بينما تستمر عمليه الاجلاء
للرعايه الاجانب حيث اتهم الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع بارتكاب انتهاكات ضدها
بعثات دبلوماسيه ليله امس هذا وذكر الجيش
السوداني في البيان ان عناصر من الدعم
السريع اعتدت على السفير الماليزي والبعثه
القطري المتجهه الى بورسودان كما تعرض
موكب السفاره الفرنسيه لاطلاق النار مما
ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل عمليه الاجلاء في
المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
ان الطائرات الجيش هي التي استهدفت موكب
السفاره الفرنسيه وشددت الدعم السريع على
التزامها بالهدنه وتسهيل حركه الرعايه
الاجانب لمناطق الاجلاء
[تصفيق]
من جانبه اكد قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان محمد حمدان دقلو لمنسق السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
اتزان قواته المطلق بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه مضيفه ان قوته مستعده لتقديم ما
يلزم من تسهيلات تساعد المواطنين
والجاليات الاجنبيه على المرور الى اماكن
امنه
وعلى صعيد الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه لوقف
التصعيد في السودان تلقى وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه اتصالا من نظيره البريطاني بحث
خلال هذا الاتصال التطورات المتسارعه في
السودان واوضاع الاجانب العالقين هناك حيث
اكد الطرفان على اهميه وقف التصعيد في
السودان وحمايه المدنيين وضروره توفير
ممرات امنه للراغبين بمغادره السودان
مشاهدينا ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي نراه
الان على الشاشه اشتباكات متقطعه في
الخرطوم مع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء عبر
ميناء بورد سودان اذا كما تابعنا هذا
العاجل باخر التحديث عن تطورات الارض في
السودان اشتباكات متقطعه في الخرطوم مع
استمرار عمليات الاجلاء عبر ميناء
كما بحث مشاهدينا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اتصالي هاتفيا مع
رئيس الوزراء القطري ووزير الخارجيه محمد
بن عبد الرحمن بن جاسم الثاني جهود وقف
التصعيد العسكري في السودان وناقش
الوزيران ايضا جهود توفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين السودانيين وتهدئه توترات
المتصاعده في البلدين من المواقع الحيويه
داخل السودان
هذا وافاد مراسل عربيه باستمرار عمليات
الاجلاء من السودان الى مدينه جده
السعوديه مشيرا الى ان دفعه جديده ستصل
خلال ساعات
يضم ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من جده سلطان
السلمي مراسل العربيه سلطان يعني اخر
التحديثات حول وصول
يعني
المواطنين الذين تم اجلاءهم من السودان
الى جده طبعا لينتقلوا بعد الى دولهم والى
اماكن سكنهم ماذا عن الدفعه الجديده التي
ستصل الى هناك
بعد وصول 157 شخص من ضمنهم 91 مواطن سعودي
و66 من دول الشقيقه نتحدث عن الامارات
وقطر والكويت وكندا والسودان وكذلك من
بنجلاديش تم اجلائهم عبر خمسه سفن بحريه
تابع للقوات السعوديه البحريه مساء يوم
امس نتحدث ان هذه السفن اربعه سفن بحريه
رئيسيه وسفينه الخامسه هي السفينه للتمويم
استغرقت عمليات الاجلاء بدلا من الخرطوم
وصولا الى ميناء مدينه بورت سودان وهي
مسافه نتحدث على 800 وخمسين كيلو متر بين
الخرطوم وبين بورسودان برا ومن ثم بحرا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه نتحدث على
رحله استغرقت 14 ساعه من بين رصيف البحر
الخاص ببورسودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه وهم يتمتعون بكامل الصحه
وتتم تقديم لهم كافه الرعايه الطبيه
والصحيه والاجتماعيه وتم اخذ جوازات السفر
وانهاء كافه الخاصه بهم وتمت عمليات
تسكينهم في مدينه جده عبر اربعه فنادق
فيما يتعلق بعمليه الاجلاء الثانيه من
المتوقع انه فجر يوم الاثنين غدا في تمام
الساعه السادسه وخمسه واربعين دقيقه سوف
تصل سفينه واحده على متنها دبلوماسيين
ومسؤولين من شتى الدول العالميه نتحدث على
دول مختلفه كان قد طلبت من الحكومه
السعوديه والسفر السعوديه في الخرطوم ان
يقوموا بعمليات اجلائهم وتمت الموافقه على
بعض الطلبات من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
والمتوقع وصولهم في تمام الساعه السادسه
وخمسه واربعين دقيقه الى تمام الساعه 9:45
صباحا من يوم غد فجر الاثنين سوف تكون
سفينه واحده بحسب ما وصل الينا حتى هذه
اللحظه نتحدث على عمليات كبيره تعمل عليها
الحكومه السعوديه والسفاره السعوديه وكذلك
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه من خلال استقبال
والتنسيق فيما يتعلق بعمليه الاجلاء كان
في مقدمه من استقبل كافه من تم اجلائهم
مساء امس نائب وزير الخارجيه السعودي
الاستاذ وليد وعدد كبير من القوات قيادات
والقوات السعوديه تم التاكد من صحتهم
وسلامتهم وتوفير كافه الخدمات اللوجستيه
الخاصه بهم وكذلك تم تسكنهم ونقلهم الى
فناقهم الاستراحه فيما يتعلق بغير
السعوديين سوف يتم انهاء كافه اجراءاتهم
ومن ثم متى ما سوف يرغبون بالذهاب الى
بلدانهم سوف يتم انهاء كافه اجراءاتهم
والتسهيل لعمليات وصولهم الى بلدان سلطان
هل يمكن الحديث عن عدد اجمالي حتى الساعه
من الذين يعني تم اجلاءهم الى الى جده وما
هي الاعداد المرتقبه في الساعات المقبله
اذا ما كان هناك اي اعداد يعني تقريبيه
فيما يتعلق بالعدد الرسمي الذي وصل يوم
امس كما اعلنت عن وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
ومئه وسبعه وخمسين شخص من ضمنهم 91 مواطن
سعودي و66 مواطن اجنبي غير السعودي من دول
الخليجيه وعربيه ودول اوروبيهكندا
وبلغاريا فيما يتعلق بالدفعه الثانيه من
المتوقع ان تتراوح اعداء بين الخمسين الى
السبعين شخص لم يتم تاكيد هذا الرقم حتى
هذه اللحظه سوف يتبين معنا خلال الساعات
القادمه فيما يتعلق بالاعداد وعدد السفن
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه هي سفينه واحده كما هو
معلوم لدينا من المتوقع ان تزداد هذه
السفن انه لازال تستمر السعوديه باتمام
عمليات الاجلاء من بورت سودان الى ميناء
او رصيف البحر الخاص بقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بحسب التنسيق مع بعض الدول
الاشقاء والدول الاجنبيه وكذلك فيما يتعلق
بانه ناكد كذلك انه تم انها او تم اجلاء
كافه المواطنين السعوديين في الى مدينه
جده من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تبقى
فقط بعض الدبلوماسيين في السفاره السعوديه
هناك سلطان ماذا عن التنسيق مع يعني
فريقين النزاع هناك الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع حول عمليات الاجلاء
الحكومه السعوديه تعمل بتنسيق عالي وكبير
جدا بين كافه الاطراف هنالك في السودان
لضمان وصول وتنقل اللاجئ سوف يتم اجلائهم
من الخرطوم برا الى بورسودان هناك تنسيق
عالي وكبير من قبل الحكومه السعوديه وكافه
الاطراف هناك في السودان لضمان سلامه كافه
ما يتم عمليه اجلائهم الى بورسودان حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول الى السفن البحريه
السعوديه هنالك في بورسودان وصولا الى
مدينه جده هنالك تنسيق طوال الساعات
الماضيه ولا زالت تنسيق جاري من قبل
الحكومه السعوديه ووزاره الخارجيه تحديدا
وبين كافه الاطراف هنالك في السودان
هذا التنسيق يعني هل كان هناك اي عمليات
خرق خلال الساعات الماضيه ام يعني هناك
التزام بعمليه النقل السلميه التي تراعي
كل يعني الشروط الانسانيه لعمليات النقل
التقينا بعدد من المسؤولين السعوديين في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه تحدثنا عن
القوات البحريه او حتى ممثلي وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه والقطاعات العامله
والمنسقه والتي تعمل على استجلاء اجلاء
الرعايه السعوديه وغير السعوديين من
السودان الى مدينه جده اكدوا انه لم يكن
هنالك اي اختراق امني او اي او اي ضرر او
اي اشكاليات تذكر حصلت لهم اثناء تنقلهم
من الخرطوم الى بورسودان وصولا الى مدينه
جده سلطان هل يعني التقيتم اي من
المواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم الى جده ان
كان سعوديين او من جنسيات اخرى
لرفض مشاهداتهم ما الذي عاشوه هناك
بالفعل التقينا بعدد كبير من تم من تم
اجلائهم من السودان نتحدث التقينا باحد
الاشخاص وهو من بلغاريا وتحدثنا كذلك مع
سيده كنديه وعدد من السعوديين التي تم
اجلائهم من السودان جميعهم وصفوا انه
الاوضاع ماساويه وخطيره جدا في السودان
مما دعاهم ان يقوموا بعمليه الاجلاء في
اقرب وقت ممكن هذا معامله الحكومه
السعوديه الوضع هنالك فوضوي بشكل كبير
وخطير جدا وتحديدا في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم كانت هنالك اشكاليات كبيره لدى
كافه من يسكن هذه العاصمه من السعوديين او
حتى غير السعوديين وكافه الرعايه او
الجاليات التي تسكن الخرطوم بالفعل تحدث
هنالك وضع ماساوي كبير جدا هنالك شحف
المياه شحف الاطعمه كذلك انقطاع الكهرباء
بشكل كبير جدا هنالك انفلات امني كبير جدا
مما دعى ان تدخل الحكومه السعوديه بشكل
فوري وسريع جدا وان تقوم باجلاء رعاياها
وكذلك
اجلاء عدد من المواطنين الدول الاوروبيه
والدوله الخليجيه والعربيه تحدثوا انه انه
الحكومه السعوديه عملت على تقديم كافه
الخدمات واستجابت لكافه طلباتهم اثناء
تقديم لهم في السفاره تحدثوا بشكل كبير
جدا عن خدمات لوجستيه وخدماته عاشيه وكذلك
توفير الامن والحمايه لهم حتى وصولهم الى
مدينه جده واكدوا ووصلوا شكروا من القياده
السعوديه وكافه العاملين في عمليات
الاجلاء سلطان يعني معظم
الرعايه الاجانب هم من العاملين في
السفارات او في البعثات الدبلوماسيه او في
الهيئات الدوليه هل الامر نفسه يعني ينطبق
ايضا عن المواطنين العرب الموجودين هناك
ام انه هناك مواطنين عاديين يعني كانوا
اصلا موجودين بالعاصمه قبل وقوع
الاشتباكات
شخصيات مختلفه تم اجلائهم نتحدث على
الدبلوماسيين ومسؤولين وكذلك عاملين في
سفارات اجنبيه وايضا اشخاص كانوا موظفين
في السودان في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
تم اجلاء كافه هؤلاء الاشخاص من
الدبلوماسيين والمسؤولين وكذلك نتحدث انه
تم على سبيل المثال هنالك فيما يتعلق
بالبعث الدبلوماسيه الخاصه بدوله الكويت
تم اجلائها بالكامل هم عددهم 22 شخص مما
جعل وزيره الخارجيه الكويتي يقدم شكره
مساء البارحه الى وزيره خارجيه السعودي
على عمليه الاجلاء الامنه كذلك يتحدث عن
مبادات دبلوماسيه اوروبيه وغير اوروبيه
نتحدث كذلك عن بعثات اخرى عربيه نتحدث على
فلسطين ومصر والسودان وايضا بعثات اخرى
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالخليج نتحدث على قطر
والكويت والامارات فتنوعت الشخصيات
والجنسيات بشكل كبير على كل حال لسلطان
سنبقى نتابع معك عمليه اجلاء المواطنين
العرب والاجانب هذه العمليات الاجلاء التي
ترعاها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
بورتسودان وصولا الى مدينه جده
في الكويت عاد اليوم 25 مواطنا قادمين من
مطار جده الدولي في السعوديه وذلك خلال في
اطار الخطه الطارئه التي نفذتها وزاره
الخارجيه الكويتيه لاجلاء المواطنين
العالقين جراء الاشتباكات المسلحه
والتطورات الامنيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
صرح وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان للعربيه بان
جنوب السودان قامت باستقبال اكثر من 3000
لاجئ من السودان ومستعده لاستقبال المزيد
منهم كما قال بان رئيس جنوب السودان اجرى
مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس المصري لحث
البرهان على الموافقه لوقف اطلاق النار
لقد قمنا باستقبال مجموعه من السودانيين
لسنوات عده وامنا ماواهم ونحن سعيدون لهذا
ولدينا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من
السودان يعيشون بكرامه في جنوب السودان
ونحن مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد منهم ان
رئيسنا اجر مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس
المصري وتطرق للوضع الحالي وكيف يمكنهما
العمل على حث البرهان لوقف اطلاق النار
والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات وذلك لوقف
الخلافات بين الطرفين المتحاربين
افادت مصادر العربيه باعطاء مصر الضوء
الاخضر لبدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
حيث قالت المصادر ان الجيش المصري ينسق مع
نظيره السوداني لبدء العمليات كما اشارت
مصادر العربيه ان الجيش السوداني سيتولى
مرافقه قوافل المصريين حتى المعابر
الحدوديه وان السودان زودت مصر بتفاصيل
الممرات الامنه لنقل المصريين لاماكن
الاجلاء هذا وكانت مصر نشرت قوات امنيه
على معابرها الحدوديه مع السودان لتامين
عمليات الاجلاء
معنا من القاهره اشرف العشري الكاتب
الصحافه ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام استاذ
اشرف سابدا بعمليات الاجلاء والتنسيق بين
الجانب المصري والجانب السوداني هل هناك
اي معطيات اضافيه عن هذا الموضوع لو سمحت
مساء الخير ست العيال بكل التاكيد اعتقد
تنسيق المصري السوداني كان قائم في الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه وصل ذروته بالامس واليوم
ايضا بعد ظهر اليوم قرر الجانب المصري
البدء عمليا في اجلاء الرعايه المصريين من
داخل اراضي السودانيه خاصه مناطق الخرطوم
ودعا كل المصير الموجودين في كافه اقاليم
السودان بالالتقاء في اقرب نقاط فيما
يتعلق القنصليه المصريه في بورسودان
والقدسيه المصريه في الخرطوم وايضا مكتب
وادي حلفا القنصلي لتسجيل اسمائهم
والاتصال بهم لتوفير ملزات امنه حتى يمكن
بالفعل تجميعهم في كثير من بعض القوافل
البريه لان جزء كبير من الاعتماد المصري
على ترحيل وعوده المصريين سيعتمد على
الطرق البريه باعتبار انها ملاصقه الحضور
السودانيه والاوسع والاكبر وتصور باعداد
كبيره خاصه اذا عرفنا ان الاعداد المصريه
مثيره للدهشه والاهتمام هناك تسجيل الرسمي
داخل السفاره المصريه في الخرطوم 10000
فقط الاعداد غير الرسميه والتقديرات حسب
المعطيات المصريه مئه الف مصري في قطاعات
كنت اسال عنه يعني هو رقم كبير جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا وبالتالي الجان
المصري سيكون الاكثر عبئا عن كل دول
العالم الموجوده في السودان باعتبار ان
هناك اعداد كبيره بالاضافه لانها تعتمد
على الطريق البري وقطع مسافات طويله
والحدود المصريه السودانيه 1300 كيلو متر
وبالتالي سيكون هناك نقاط تمركز وتموضع
تقدم فيها سلطات المصريه عبر اجهزه الجيش
واجهزه الاستخبارات المصريه كثير من بعض
نقاط الفرعيه لامكانيه التقاط المصريين من
داخل حدود السودانيه بالتوافق والترتيب
والتنسيق مع الجيش السوداني حتى يكون هناك
عمليه تامين شامله لقواف العوده المصريين
عمليه التنسيق استاذ اشرف ستكون فقط مع
الجانب الجيش السوداني او ستكون مع طرفي
النزايه الجيش الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني
اعتقد في المقام الاول ستكون مع الجيش
السوداني باعتبار انه يتولى الدرجه كبيره
من السيطره وايضا التمركز الطماط داخل
كثير من الخرطوم وادي حلفا وايضا وخرطوم
بحري وبالتالي الجيش السوداني لديه درجه
كبيره من توفير الحمايه لكميه من الحافلات
الكبرى التي سوف
والدعم السريع اعتقد لا يمكن باي حال من
يوفر هذه التامينات خاصه ان لدى القاهره
بعد شقوق بعد حارس اسر الكتيبه المصريه في
مروي وان هناك تركيز على الجانب السوداني
ان الجيش ويمثل الشرعيه في السودان ولديه
درجه كبيره من التنسيق واللصق في جهد مع
الجانب المصري
اقرب نقطه حدود مصريه سودانيه استاذه اشرف
يعني بالجانب الاخر انت تتحدث عن 100 الف
مصري موجودين داخل السودان هناك ايضا
تقارير عن استقبال مصر والقاهره تحديدا
يعني لاكثر من خمسه ملايين سوداني فروا
بالفتره الماضيه من الفقر ومن القتال
وهناك ايضا يعني اتفاقيه لحركه
للحركه بين البلدين اليوم مع هذا النزاع
المسلح هناك حركه نزوح كثيفه من داخل
السودان هل هناك اجراءات جديده لمنع دخول
مزيد من السودانيين الى داخل مصر
هذه نقطه جوهريه تمثل الاولويه القصوى
لجانب المصري مبدئيا لن يكون هناك اغلاق
حدود مصريه باتجاه الاخوه في السودان حسب
معطيات المتوفره لديها حتى لا تتهم مصر
بانها اغلقت ابوابها وايضا على التوفير
مظلات الاغاثه للشعب السوداني خاصه هناك
علاقات وثيقه وازليه وهناك ايضا ارتباط
حدودي ببالغ الاهميه وارتباط حتى على
مستوى المصاهره والكربه بين كثير من
السودانيين وايضا سكان مصر في الجنوب
اسوان وغيرها من الاراضي المصريه وحتى
شيلاتين وحلايكه وبالتالي سيكون صعبا على
الدوله المصريه ان تغلق هذه الحدود بهذا
امر ربما يكون غير وارد في حسان لكن هناك
ايضا معطيات جديده فيما يتعلق بتجهيز خليه
ازمه مصريه لنقل المصريين وفي نفس الوقت
ايضا استقبال السودانيين بشرط ان تتوافر
لائحه مطالب وضمانات مصريه لمن لديهم حريه
التنقل والدخول في مصر طبقا اتفاقيات
الحدود الحريات الاربع منها حريه التنقل
بين البلدين دون تاشيرات بمجرد البطاقه
الشخصيه او حامل الهويه الشخصيه بكده
البلدين عبء كبير على الجانب المصري فيما
يتعلق بالتدقيق في من يدخل الى حدود خاصه
ان هناك الحدود كانت منذ 2011 حتى ثوره
للجامعات الارهابيه وتهريب السلاح وكميات
كبيره من دخلت للارض المصريه قبل ثوره
2013 وتم استغلالها في سيناء ضد الدوله في
اعمال ارهابيه وبالتالي الدوله بعد 2013
وضعت قيود وتنسيقات امنيه بالغه الحزم
والحزم مع الجانب السوداني وبالتالي سيتم
فتح الحدود في استقبال الاخوه السودانيين
لكن طبقا لمن تتواصل لديهم اشتراطات عمليه
تدقيق كامله في كل من لدى الرؤى رغبه في
دخول مصر خاصه في مناطق الجنوب واسوان
تحديدا اشرف ابقى معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك
مشاهدينا ساشير الى هذه العواجل التي ترد
الان حزب الامه القوميه السودانيه للعربيه
يقول بان تصريحات البرهان وحمه تشير الى
انهما استدرجا استدرجه للحرب اذا كان هذا
تصريح لحزب الامه السوداني
الامه القوميه السوداني للعربيه حول اخر
التطورات داخل السودان وايضا حزب الامه
يقول نقترح استضافه البرهان واحمد في حوار
بدوله اقليميه اذا ساكمل هذه التغطيه قبل
ان اعود اليك استاذ اشرف ساذهب الى
مراسلنا من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي لرصد اخر
التطورات الميدانيه سالم سابدا مع
الاشتباكات المتقطعه في الخرطوم والتي
تستمر مع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء عبر
ميناء بورتسودان الى اي مدى تؤثر على
عمليات الاجلاء
نعم بدايه هناك
هدوء نسبي في مناطق متعدده من ولايه
الخرطوم تشهد هدوءا حذرا في المناطق التي
تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات ثانيا بالنسبه
لعمليات الاجل عمليات
هذه عمليات الاجابه التي تحدث اليوم
ستكون من قاعده الجويه في وادي سيدنا وهي
قاعده تتبع للقوات المسلحه السودانيه وهي
في ام سالم سالم
اسمح لي يعني الان بالصوره المباشره على
الهواء من الخرطوم نرى اعمده نيران كثيفه
وكان يعني هناك اشتباكات دائره بهذه
الاثناء ماء يعني ما الخبر وراء هذه هذا
الدخان المتصاعد
الاشتباكات كانت
الحاديه عشره تقريبا مهرا ثم بدات هذه
الى ان وصلت الى ادنى مستوياتها منذ
اندلاع هذه الازمه هي هذه ربما تكون اطول
فتره يتم فيها هدوء نسبي وحدث في المناطق
التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات خلال هذا
اليوم ايضا اليوم شهد حركه اشبه بالطبيعيه
في المناطق التي لا توجد بها صراعات او
نزاعات او لا تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات كذلك
هذا ايضا تخلله خلال اليوم بعض القنابل
وبعض مدافع الصوتيه والمضادات للطائرات
كذلك لكنها ايضا ليست بذات الوتيره التي
كانت عليها
في الايام الماضيه فيما يخص الاجلاء
الجلاء الرعايه كان هو لرعايه الاتحاد
الاوروبي بشكل عام سيكون او بدا بالفعل
هذا الاجلاء وسيتم اجراءهم من القاعده
العسكريه للقاعده سيدنا وهي قاعده في اقصى
شمال ام درمان بالقرب من الكليه الحربيه
قاعده وادي سيدنا تتبع لسلاح الجو الذي
يتبع للجيش السوداني
تحط هناك طائرات وستجلي العديد من الرعايه
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي ومنهم الفرنسيون
بكل تاكيد
وقد بدات هذه العمليات عمليات الادلاء
بالفعل خلال اليوم
وستستمر الى ان تنتهي
تنتهي هذا الاله لكل الرعايه الموجودين
هنا
اذا يعني بالتوقيت عمليات الاجلاء ستستمر
حتى انتهاء الهدنه او لما بعد انتهاء
الهدنه وماذا سيحصل من بعده
الهدنه هي الان السادسه مساء
انها تكون قد انتهت هذه الهديه لكن ماذا
يخيل انه وايضا يعيد ونكرر ايضا انه في كل
مره يتم الاعلان عن هدنه لا يتم الالتزام
بادنه بشكل كامل هناك التزام بالهدنه بشكل
نسبي في في مختلف الايام الماضيه ولكن
الالتزام الكامل لم يحدث حتى الان التزام
كامل من كل الاطراف
حاجه لتنسيق فعل مع اطراف النزاع لاكمال
عمليات الاجلاء بالساعات المقبله
صحيح بكل تاكيد تحتاج الى تنسيق بين
الاطراف من اجل ان يتم الاجلاء بشكل
ممتاز وهو الى الان يتم بصوره ممتازه لا
يوجد اي فروقات حتى نتحدث عن الوصول الى
المناطق عدا ما جاءت من التهم
هذه القوات الدعم السريع من التهم التي
وجهها الجيش السوداني
على المطلب الفرنسي وكذلك ما تم
السفاره او المندوبين والسفراء او البعثه
عفوا الدبلوماسيه التابعه لدوله قطر
بالاضافه الى الماليزي كل هذه الامور التي
تحدثت عنها الجيش السوداني من اعتداءات
وجاء بعد ذلك الدعم السريع ورد كذلك على
انه لم يقوم بهذا الامر وانه هناك طرف اخر
يرتدي الدعم السريع هو من يقوم بهذه
الاعمال من اجل ان يجعل الدعم السريع مجرم
في نظر المجتمع الدولي لكن مع تبادل هذه
الاتهامات
الواقع انه الان بدا الاجراء
بدا الاجلاء الان بالفعل ونحن نتوقع بعد
انتهاء الهدنه ان يكون هناك معارك دار بين
الطرفين خصوصا يعني مع الصور المتداوله
لوجود احمدتي على الارض مع المقاتلين
وايضا يعني عن انباء اخرى عن عمليات حشد
بالخرطوم هل دخلنا ساعات المواجهه ما بعد
الهدنه ام ماذا
نعم ربما هذا الكلام صحيح لكن دعينا ايضا
نقول ان هناك الان مبادرات وطنيه هي تجتهد
في ان توقف هذه الحرب
وتمد مدى الهدنه ومن ثم بعد ذلك يجلس
الطرفين لاجل ان يصلوا الى رؤيه مشتركه او
حتى حل القضيه لكن لغه الخطاب التي يتم
الحديث بها ما بين القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه والقاعده الدعم السريع هي لغه لا
توحي بقرب انتهاء الازمه او البحث عن حوار
لان هناك لغه تصعيد وكذلك لغه تتحدث عن
مطالب مطالب عالي جدا نعم وتحدي وسقف
مطالب عالي كذلك في لغه الرجلين هذا الامر
ربما يجعل من مساله
القرب من حل هذه الازمه غير منطقي في هذه
الايام لكن وربما يحدث اختراق اذا تم
الالتزام بهذه الهدنه وهذا ما ظلت تردده
الكثير من القوى السياسيه وايضا يردده
كذلك المراقبون والمحللون بانه اذا تم
التزام بهدنه لفتره طويله ربما تكون هي
ارضيه لبدايه لحوار بين الرجلين او الوصول
الى حل يرضي الطرفين
بصوره المعارك والاشتباكات على الارض
اليوم اين تتركز قوات الدعم السريع اين
تتركز قوات الجيش غير محيط القياده العامه
الذي يعني من البديهي ان يكون الطرفان
موجودان هناك
تنتشر في المناطق التي
تحيط بها المعسكرات التابعه للقوات الدعم
السريعه وبالقرب منها على بعض المعسكرات
ومثل معسكر الذي قد وضع الجيش السوداني
يده عليه بالكامل وبعض المعسكرات الاخرى
لكن في الخرطوم هنا
في منطقه في مدينه بحرين في الشعبيه وفي
المزاد وفي الصافيه وكذلك جزء من شبات حي
شنبات وكذلك الاحياء الاخرى المجاوره
كافوري ايضا تنتشر هناك قوات للدعم السريع
في الشوارع الرئيسيه ولديها ارتكازات
واضحه
وايضا يعني الى كوبري الشنبات
كل هذه المناطق تنتشر فيها القوات الدعم
السريع
بالبعد عن هذه المناطق لا توجد دعم سريع
والوضع هناك اقل خطوره ربما يكون كذلك
ايضا في محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون مثلا بعض
القوات التابعه للدعم السريع ايضا في
منطقه صالح
نتحدث عن خارطه معقده جدا بين الطرفين
ويعني مما ينذر الى
نعم فعلا ان نقول ان هذه الجهه الى الان
يعني وهذا من الامور المحموده حتى الان
انه لا توجد الان منطقه يقال انها تتبع
للدعم السريع وهذه تتبع للجيش لانه ما
زالت هي فقط قوات منتشره تشترك مع قوات
اخرى
على كل حال
على كل حال سالم ساعود اليك طبعا خلال هذه
التغطيه شكرا لك مشاهدينا نكمل وساشير الى
ان يعني بالصوره التي نشاهدها العربيه
ترصد اعمده الدخان في سماء الخرطوم التي
تشهد اشتباكات متقاطعه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن اجلاء
100 شخص من السودان على ان يتبعهم 100
اخرون فيما كشف مصدرا فرنسيا للعربيه ان
فرنسا ستجلي رعاياها بطائرتين عبر مطار
يبعد 20 كم عن الخرطوم مؤكده ان طائره نقل
الرعايه الفرنسيين ستتجهان الى جيبوتي
في الاثناء صرحت وزاره الدفاع والخارجيه
الالمانيتان ان برلين بدات باجلاء رعاياها
من السودان في ظل استمرار المعارك بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع كما
اوضحت لوزرتان عبر منصه تويتر ان الهدف هو
نقل اكبر عدد من الرعايه الالمان من
الخرطوم ضمن الامكانات طبعا وستساعد في
نقل رعايه دول اخرى من الاتحاد الاوروبي
هذا ونشرت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه صورا
لما قالت انها عمليه اجلاء مدنيين من
الخرطوم باتجاه بورتسودان ولم تحدد
الوكاله اذا كانت العمليه تخص نقل
دبلوماسيين اجانب ام رعايه دول اجنبيه
مقيمين في الخرطوم فلنتابع
الى ذلك قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك ان القوات المسلحه اتمت عمليه
اجراء معقده وسريعه للديبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من السودان مضيفا
ان بريطانيا تسعى بكل الوسائل لوقف اراقه
الدماء في السودان وضمان سلامه
البريطانيين المتبقين هناك مؤكدا انها تحث
الاطراف كافه على القاء الاسلحه وايقاع في
اطلاق النار
من جانبه قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بنواز
ان عمليه الاجلاء جاءت بسبب تهديدات
المتصاعده جراء المواجهات في السودان
مشيرا الى مشاركه 1200 جندي بريطاني في
العمليه من ضمنهم 16 لواء هجوم جوي ومشاه
البحريه الملكيه والسلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني
هذا واكد مشاهدينا نائب رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني اوليفر
بان الوضع في السودان معقد ويتصاعد بوتيره
سريعه فلنستمع لمقاله
من الواضح ان الوضع في السودان سريع
الوتيره ومعقد
اولوياتنا هي دعم الرعايه البريطانيين
ويعمل وزير الدفاع الان لدعم وزاره
الخارجيه لكن لن اعلق لاسباب الامنيه على
الوضع الحالي من حيث التحركات على الارض
اعد مشاهدينا الى القاهره
الكاتب الصحفي ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
استاذ اشرف يعني بالفتره الماضيه بالاتفاق
الحاصل اتفاق يعني التنقل بين السودان
والقاهره كانت تسير حوالي 37 الف رحله
شهريا اتحدث هنا عن 25 قافله يوميا اليوم
مع تصاعد الصراع هناك مع اشتداد المعارك
ومع الهجره التي تقدر بالملايين هل سيتم
تقليص هذا العدد ام يعني سيبقى على ما هو
لكن انه سيساعد في اتجاه واحد اي اتجاه
العائدين من الاراضي السودانيه باتجاه
الحدود المصريه في محاوله لتوفير حظوظ
الانقاذ للشبكات الانقاذ لكثير من
السودانيين سواء المصريين العدد كبير في
مصر مصر تحت حملت الحمل الثقيل في اعداد
كبيره مئه الف وبالتالي لابد الحكومه
المصريه ان تلعب دورا كبيرا في اجلائهم
بقدر باقل قدر من التوفيق والنجاح
والتامين واعتقد ان لدي خبره فعلت نفس هذا
الامر في ليبيا منذ عام 2011 بعد العقيده
القذافي نفس المقاسات اتعرض لها الجاليه
المصريه او التواجد المصري المدني داخل
الاراضي السودانيه وبالتالي القاهره ستلعب
دورا فيما يتعلق بعمليه نقل باحترافيه
وتامين كامل وسيكون ايضا استقبال لاعداد
رهيبه من السودانيين من بعض يتوقع ان يكون
هناك كرامه الاثنين مليون ونص الى 2 مليون
بالاضافه الى 5 مليون قائمين في الداخل
المصري السودانيين والقاهره تستطيع ان
تحجب اي شخص سوداني لان هناك اتفاقيه
التحولات الاربعه موقعه عام 2004 واربعه
تنص على ضروره حريه التنقل دون اي عوائق
الا في الاشتراطات والامنيه لمن يلجا الى
اعمال عنف او ارهاب وبالتالي سيكون الزمن
على الدوله المصريه ان تسمح بمرور اي
اعداد سودانيه في المرحله القادمه سيكون
هناك مضاعفه اعداد الرحلات بالفعل لكن
الاتجاه من الداخل السوداني باتجاه الحدود
المصريه وهذا سوف يستلزم ان يكون خليه
ازمه مصريه مشكله من كافه الاجازه
الاختصاصيه قوات المسلحه استخبارات مصريه
امنيه حتى الاجهزه المعونه في الشان
الانساني لامكانيه توفير ما يتعلق بمناطق
الاقامه وهم مخيمات اذا اقتدى الامر ومن
يريد الوصول الى القاهره او اسوان للاقارب
والاهل من السودان يرتبط بعلاقات نسب
ومصهره او قربه مع جانب سوداني سيكون على
الجانب المصري توفير كل هذه الملزات
الامنه حتى يتم وصولهم بسلام في محاوله
لان يكون دور مصري داعم للسودان في هذه
المحنه التي يعيشها الجانب السوداني خاصه
لعلاقات وثقه ومترابطه وسلامه تمثل لمصر
العمق الاستراتيجي ولا يمكن تتخلف هذا
الظرف وهذه الرضاعه الدقيقه عن الجانب
السوداني لانه يكون هناك كبيره من القيام
مصر بدور حيوي عندما تحين او تتحين الظروف
او الفرصه لامكانيات لعب دور سياسي في
الازمه الحاليه سواء
اشرف يعني الجانب المصري والجانب السوداني
كان قد اعلن عن ممرين بكل ولايه سودانيه
لنقل المصريين بالولايات العاديه باماكن
شديده الاشتباك سيتم تخصيص ثلاث الى اربع
ممرات امنه لنقل المصريين الى المعابر
الحدوديه وطبعا سيكون هناك انتشار للعناصر
المسلحه على الحدود لتقييم الوضع وعمليات
الاجلاء اتحدث عن عناصر المسلحه المصريه
طبعا ولكن عمليات الاجلاء ستجمد في الليل
تجويد عمليات النقل خلال الليل هل سيطيل
يعني امد عمليات النقل الى القاهره ويعقد
اكثر المشهد خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن احتماليه
اشتداد المعارك كثيرا بين الجانبين ما بعد
انتهاء هدنه العيد
بالفعل سيعكر وسيطول ازمه نقل هؤلاء ووصول
من القاهره سواء المصريين او السودانيين
لا تنسي الغرض من اغلاق الحريه ليلا هو ان
يكون ضبط للحدود الحدود ليست سائبه كما
كان قبل عام 2011 هناك كاميرات رادارات
مصريه عطريقه كبيره من الجوزيه مثلها مثل
الحدود المصريه الليبيه القاهره عانت من
حدود المصريه السودانيه الحدود المصريه
الليبيه على سبيل المثال اعطيك مثالا برقم
قاتل وهو تهريب 11 مليون قطعه سلاح من
الاراضي الليبيه باتجاه الاراضي المصريه
هناك توقعات بدا اعداد نصف هذا العدد او
اكثر القليل تم تهريبه الى داخل الاراضي
المصريه منذ عام 2011 مما ادى الى نمو
وتغذيه العناصر الارهابيه للقيام بعمليات
في الدخل المصري كانت شديده الواطئه
وبالتالي الجانب المصري تعلم الدرس تماما
واستطاع ان يسيب الحدود المصريه السودانيه
مثلها مثل حدود الليبيه بشبكات انذار مبكر
ومراقبه بالغه الاهميه انفقت القاهره
الملايين الدولارات من اجل تامين هذا
التامين حمايه ان وجود نظام يعني مقسم
اليوم وضعيف داخل الخرطوم يؤثر وله
تداعيات طبعا على الامن القومي المصري هنا
يعني بهذه الناحيه ايضا يعني هناك ايضا
نواحي انسانيه للمواطنين السودانيين الذين
يعانون داخل داخل المنطقه وممكن ان ينزحوا
الى الحدود المحاذيه في حال لم يتم السماح
لهم بالدخول الى مصر الى القاهره هل ستكون
هناك اجراءات جديده لم نعهدها من قبل على
الحدود السودانيه المصريه
اعتقد انه يكون هناك نوع من الحظر فيما
يتعلق بالدخول السودانيين الا من لديه صله
او على الاقل لديه كشوف فيما يتعلق
بجامعات ارهابيه او مسانده او دعم او في
لحظه ما من لحظات عندما كان هناك حكومه
البشير اتجاه لدي مواقف عاديه باتجاه
الدوله المصريه الجزء الاخر ان الدوله
المصريه راغبه فان يكون هناك تمرير او
مرور هذه العمليه للسودانيين بامان كبير
وان هناك رغبه مصريه في مساعدات الجانب
السوداني على مستوى الانساني ومستوى ايضا
البشري طالما ان الظروف الاقتصاديه
السياسيه معقده للغير العسكريه ما زالت
قائمه فالجانب المصري يريد ان يكون هناك
تسهيلات او يبدي حسن النوايا او يوفر كثير
من المقومات الاستحقاق استحقاق الدعم
الكامل الاخوه السودانيين فيما يتعلق غاس
الانسانيه والاغاثه البشريه والصحيه في
المقام الاول حتى ان هناك كثير من بعض
قوافل وهو تفكر فيها القاهره حسب معطياتي
الامكانيات دخول الاراضي السودانيه عندما
تهدا اعمال العنف والتوتر ويكون هناك
بالفعل فرض اشتباك بين حمدتي والبرهان عبر
قوتهما المتحاربه لمساعده الجانب السوداني
في الاغاثه الطبيه والانسانيه في هذا
الشام كل الخلاصه فيما الحدود ليليه هو
ايضا منع تسرب مصريين هرب الى ليبيا
محسوبون على جماعه الاخوان والتنظيمات
الارهابيه
تخشى القاهره ان يعود هم كانوا هاربين
فيتخافوا باسماء
مستخوف من عوده هؤلاء الى النظام السوداني
استاذ اشرف ابقى معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك
مشاهدينا ساشير بان يتم لهذه العواجه التي
ترد الان تسجيل صعوبه في الاتصالات مع
السودان خصوصا مع الخرطوم طبعا هذا ربما
بسبب تضرر شبكات الاتصالات هناك وايضا
بالعواجل التي وردت قبل قليل
العربيه ترصد اذا اعمده الدخان التي كنت
قد تحدثت عنها خلال هذه التغطيه
اظهر مقطع فيديو لهجوم على سجن بالخرطوم
وانباء عن هروب سجناء فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
الشعب السوداني اكثر من اكتوى بنار هذه
الحرب القصه التاليه تحقيق فقدان عائله
لابنها نتيجه سقوط مقذوف عليه في المنزل
فلنتابع هذه القصه
في السودان الصراع متوصل بين المكونين
العسكريين
ايام المره يعيشها السودانيون الذين
تطلعوا لعهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
حياه العشرات تحولت لماساه حقيقيه بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني صراع تلو اخر عمق
الازمه وزاد من حده التممل والاستياء
ملامح الحزن والاسى خيمت على وجه ادريس
حسن الذي فقد ابن اخيه عندما اخترقت قذيفه
النافذه المنزلي ادت لمقتله على سريره
[موسيقى]
على العزال الليله فقدناه
والمرحوم ده مات في سريره
بس يعني
القصف تسبب بحروق لوالده الضحيه التي صدمت
من هول الحادثه
[موسيقى]
والله
الحياه المدنيه توقفت في السودان
مناطق سكنيه مقتظه بالسكان ومضخمه بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل ساشير الى هذه
العواجل التي وردت قبل قليل عن بلال الذي
اكد للبرهان واحمد ضروره حمايه المدنيين
وضمان اجلاء الامن الاوروبيين وايضا تحدث
الى البرهان وحماه سلاحثهما على وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار بالسودان اذا كانت هذه اخر
العواجل
لاخر التطورات داخل السودان وتصريحات طبعا
الدوليه وتحديدا الاوروبيه منها ومع
استمرار المواجهات تتفاقم الازمه الصحيه
في السودان حيث اعلن مدير منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان المؤسسات الصحيه في السودان
تعرضت لهجمه داعيا الى توقف ذلك وعلى
الفور طبعا كما واكد بانه لا ينبغي
استهداف مقدمين الرعايه الصحيه او المرافق
الصحيه لضمان تقديم الخدمات للمرضى
صرح المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر
السوداني للعربيه انه لا توجد ممرات امنه
وموثوقه لاصاله المساعدات الانسانيه
للاهالي في السودان فلنستمع لما قاله يعني
التعليقات نحن بنواجهك هلال احمد السوداني
تواجهها كل المنظمات الانسانيه العامله في
السودان اللي هي ابرز عدم توفر المسارات
الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه لهذا السبب الناس بتتجه
انها تقنع الاطراف المتنازعه ومش نحن بس
يعني كل المؤسسات الدوليه وحتى الامم
المتحده والحكومات بتسعى بين طرفي النزاع
انه تامن اوقات معلومه ايام معلومه لوقف
اطلاق النار وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه لانه بدون ضمان امن الكادر
الكادر المسؤول عن توصيل المساعدات
الانسانيه حتبقى كارثه كبيره جدا
اعلنت وزاره الصحه السودانيه عن تعذر
استقبال المرضى في مركز الغسل الكلوي
في
انه كما حيث توقف تقديم الخدمات في الصحه
قالت ان المشفى يعاني من نقص الكوادر
العامله في وقت تتكدس فيه المرضى بحثا عن
طلق العلاج الوزاره دعت الكوادر الطبيه
القريبه من مركز التعليميه للانضمام
لتقديم المساعده الطبيه العاجله وناشدت
المتطوعين واهالي المرضى بتوفير المسكن
والحوافز لاستقبال المرضى
ازمه اخرى بدات بالتفشي في السودان مع
تواصل اقتتال العسكري وتتمثل هنا بقطاع
المياه الصالحه للشرب تاثر محطات المياه
في العاصمه جراء المواجهات قوات الدعم
السريع اعلنت السماح لموظفي الكهرباء
والمياه والخدمات الصحيه بمباشره اعمالهم
فيما لم يصدر اي بيان من الجيش بهذا الصدد
الناس
المشكله بتاعه المويه
الاحداث لم يعني لا توجد اننا ماء تماما
ولا يوجد عندنا كهرباء فكل الظلام ظلام
كده مش عادي
اعمل ايه
نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا لنائب
رئيس الاركان السودانيه الفريق عباس
الدورتي بين الجنود يلقي عليهم التحيه
ويهنئهم بعيد الفطر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا باخر عاجل الان يرد على الشاشه
مصادر عربيه طائرات مدنيه وعسكريه مستمره
في نقل الرعايه الاجانب من مطار بورتسودان
وهذا طبعا كنا غطيناه مع الزميل من جده
وعن قرب وصول يعني دفعه جديده بعد ساعات
الى هناك
اعود مشاهدينا الى القاهره والاستاذ اشرف
العشري الكاتب الصحفي ومدير تحرير صحيفه
الاهرام استاذ اشرف نظام ضعيف في الخرطوم
دوله يعني
فاشله اذا صح التعبير هو تهديد للامن
القومي المصري هنا مصر اليوم يعني هي من
الراعي الاساسي ومن الدول الاساسيه التي
تتحرك على خط تحريك المياه الجامده بهذه
الازمه وطبعا ايجاد مخرج غير المخرج
الاقتتالي والدموي لهذه الازمه هناك ما
المخرج المحتمل في الايام او في الاشهر
المقبله ام اننا نتحدث عن يعني صوره قاتمه
ويعني جماد بالصوره
كل التاكيد اتفق معك ورن الصوره قاطمه
وربما ضبابيه وربما تذهب السودان الى
السنيرات الاسوا في مرحله وفي الايام
القادمه كل هذه الامور وضعتها القاهره
اعتقد في سبعه ايام الماضيه في كثير من
التفكير المصري على المستوى الاستراتيجي
سواء على مستوى صنع القرار او حتى
المؤسسات الامنيه الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه
هناك درجه كبيره من اهتمام غير اللام
متناهي بتطورات الاوضاع في صداع على مدار
الساعه تعلمين ان القاهره السودان تمثل
لنص العمق الاستراتيجي منطقه متفجره
وبالتالي القاهره ليست بحاجه الى مواقع
تفجير او صواعق تفجير جديده بعد ليبيا
وبعد ايضا الاوضاع في غزه وفي الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وحتى فيما يتعلق بالحدود
المصريه مع كثير من بعض الدول ذات النشاط
الارهابي او اقل ذات النظام اللي فيه كثير
من التشققات والتراجع والخلل في المشهد
الامني في اقليم سواء على المستوى العربي
وعلى مستوى الافريقي وبالتالي السودان
تحظى باهميه وركيزه اساسيه
ولا اخفيك سرا ان كل تقديرات فيما يتعلق
بسنوريات الاوضاع في السودان اخذت في
الاعتبار خاصه ان لدى القاهره وصناع
القرار في القاهره حسب معطياتي درجه كبيره
من الاهتمام بان هذه المعركه ستطول بشكل
كبير بشكل كبير وان هناك خشيه مصريه ان
تتحول الساحه السودانيه في لحظه ما ايه او
مكان الماء في السودان الى ان يكون هناك
شاحه مقربه للاوضاع في سوريا والاوضاع في
ليبيا ودخول جامعه الانابيع على خط الازمه
بالتالي
بهذا الصراع هناك تحميل كبير
يسمونهم فلول النظام
السابق يعني تاجيج الصراع بين الطرفين الى
اي مدى تتخوف القاهره اليوم اذا ما تحولت
السودان كما كما تفضلت من عوده هؤلاء
وتاجيج ايضا الاوضاع ان كان على الحدود
وان كان في داخل المصري
بكل تاكيد تتحسب لعوده فلول نظام السابق
ونظام هذا حسن الترابي اي مؤتمر الشعب
المؤتمر الوطني وان هناك بالقوه المضاده
للثوره السودانيه التي حدثت في عام 2019
لديهم درجه من السائريه مع النظام في
الداخل وايضا مع السلطات المصريه باعتبار
ان القاهره كانت علاقات متوتره ومتباعده
وفيها كثير من الخلل في نظام عمر البشير
وان نتولى مواقف سلبيه باتجاه القاهره مع
اثيوبيا فيما يتعلق بقريه النيل على سبيل
المثال الثاني ايضا انه وفر حاضنه
للجماعات الارهابيه محسوبه على جماعه
الاخوان وتنظيمات داخل الاراضي السودانيه
لعمليات قصف اتجاه القاهره عبر الحدود
وتهريج الاسلحه وعناصر ارهابيه وبالتالي
القاهره تريد ان يكون لديها درجه كبيره من
انضباطيه فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي مع الازمه
السودانيه وتوفر الدعم الكامل والحاضنه
العسكريه باعتبار انها الحامي للامن
والاستقرار وتريد ان يكون كل خطوه محسوبه
داخل ملعب السوداني والساحه السودانيه في
المرحله الحاليه والقادمه املا في ان يكون
هناك فعل الضوء في نهايه الن
بالتعاون مع اطراف عربيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وحتى جنوب
افريقيا لاقناع الطرفين وبالذات حبيبتي
لوقف اعمال العنف والذهاب باتجاه استراحه
محارب طويله بعدها سيكون لكل حدث حديث
فيما يتعلق به سيناريو او على الاقل
المسار التفاوضي السياسي بناء على قواعد
واسس جديده بعيدا عن اتفاق الاطاري الذي
القاهره على درجه كبيره من التوافق
والتلاقي معهم شكرا لك استاذ اشرف العشري
الكاتب الصحافه ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
على وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات